[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le petit garçon
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date si tu cherches quentin avec moi
dôme plan cette semaine au podcast
on a reçu claude bégin véritable légende
de la musique au québec ni plus ni moins
claude qui est membre de la classe ans
qui était membre accrophone avant ce qui
fait sa carrière solo aussi un
réalisateur aussi derrière beaucoup
d'artistes qu'on entend karim wallet
entre autres gosses par çi lingots qui
est choqué et très mystérieux et je
pense que le podcast permis de percer un
peu les mystères je l'avais jamais
entendu comme ce puits il est drôle et l
humour il faut ni ma coulpe hugo et
d'une grande culture d'une grande
créativité
puis goûts multiples talents aussi fait
de la photo il fait de fait la mise et
qui chante il ira pch coup belles
rencontres fait qu'on a parlé de the à
dire le drap des muses également la
réunion d'affaires c'est quoi ces
projets le justifient indiqué réaliser
pour quatre artistes la musique ou
catharsis différent avec un but qui
manquent pas d'idées de projets puis de
pain sur la planche
si vous aimez sans fil podcast on a une
chaîne pétrin
juste avant de tourner avec l'autre
belge on a tourné un podcast exclusif
pour notre page p tu es moi ce qu'on
parle entre autres de la saga michael
jackson qui est qui sujet chaud en ce
moment donc si vous voulez avoir accès à
ce podcast le aller sur notre page
pétrone c'est dans la destruction de
cette vidéo si vous allez avoir cette ce
lien le sinon abonnez-vous à notre
chaîne youtube parce qu'à chaque semaine
on continue à sortir des potiers sur les
grosses choses qui s'en viennent pour le
sans-fil broadcast pions on est bien
excité de tout d'abord est finalement un
petit talon général à tous ceux qui
écoutent le podcast si vous êtes vous
même ou si vous connaissez des gens qui
sont des graphistes donc des gens soient
des étudiants en graphisme qui ont du
temps un petit peu les fins de semaine
et cetera et cetera
vous pouvez nous écrire sans fil podcast
à gmail.com on est en recherche de
quelqu'un quelqu'un avec qui travailler
envoyez nous un petit peu des démons de
ce que vous faites puis on on va partir
de là sinon sinon bon podcast avec la
grille podcast clos de ce téléphone
les coups bas les bombes à cannes
[Musique]
yes s'est passé mon club salut salut
merci d'être là ça fait plaisir c'est
super le fun on a parlé de toi souvent
sur le podcast voyage qui s'est du coup
on a parlé de toi avec fu chi qui avait
que des bons moyens de résister ou qui
comme il fait une imitation cette
cohérence quand même loin dans notre
relation
c'était mes amis mes bêtes mais l'os
comme moi je te laisse en laisse mon ami
c'est étant au vert dans la toune bah
ouais non seulement premier buzz au
pizza est fait avec son club préféré
pis non mesdames avec marielle est
toujours arrêtée même été comme une
figure omniprésente du podcast puis jean
les autres stars vont pouvoir ou avoir
enfin savoir tai chi ouais ben tant pis
qui mais ils nous demandaient en vue
kloet
ouais bah ouais je pêchais l'agencé
grand plaisir hier tu me disais avant
qu'on avant qu'on chope des journées
acta le travail est le plus apte à vie
ouais je me défoule un peu
c'est ainsi dans le travail il ya
tellement d'aspects à mon travail
souvent il y retourne en studio ça me
fait du bien d'entendre ce foot là j'ai
comme dit oui à tout ce qui passait sur
mon chemin dans la dernier mois et ça
nous a quand même puis je suis du genre
à ces temps ci avait à dire comme oui
dans la même journée à tout comme quatre
albums différents genres de 14 15 armes
je dormais jean 3h le chef accepte tout
il ya les y passer une phase 2009
parce que claude et fait de la musique
longtemps mais il fait quand même six
mois tout jamais le petit mais il est un
titre joué aussi le jeu le jeu devient
un peu de la formation là dedans en main
on essaie de continuer à tendre la
perche
j'y connais pas grand chose la dame je
suis lent de jeter un bon travail je
respecte beaucoup les gens que j'ai
côtoyés dans ce milieu qui avaient
énormément d'expérience pis pour moi
guillaume lemay thivierge qu'il faut
qu'ils passent à première vue pourtant
premier de ces histoires de les premiers
rôles qui ont fait quelque chose qui
garde un genre d'espoir que moi c'est
vraiment la muse et puis je serais
intéressé c'est eux qui m'ont approché
comme juste dit oui puis j'ai eu à
surmonter le défi de deux premiers gros
rôle ouais mais tenez je me semble est
une personne que
j'aurais envie d'avoir dans un projet
rentre ici depuis qu'il est et de ce que
je sais de ce que tu as fait j'ai
l'impression que si je veux avoir un
projet si j'ai un projet puis j'espère
qu'il soit plein potentiel que ce soit
une série où que ce soit y j'ai
l'impression qu'un espèce de retour de
toi qui comme bon merci c'est le
multifonction pour aller plus mollo
fonction que je connais si ça dans la
zone disputée
comment ce soir jusqu'avant mode faire
l'album réalisé l'album qui fort la
poche attend entre la musique l'image
comme connectés mais la musique ou de
soie ploguer qu'ils écoutent or la carte
puis le smau laptop dans mon lit à goce
une photo pendant une heure gmt manceau
sait comment agents de relaxation fait
que j'ai comme une esquisse de photoshop
autant la photo je mets ça sur
automatiquement comme un scandale qui
volent à paris je mets sur automatique
il dit après l'ajustement photoshop la
faute à sa façon de procéder et puis non
c'est un peu un projet je pense que
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment cool qu'un
gain comme iras par exemple je travaille
sur sur quatre 4 projets dans une
journée six autres un calque aliana fait
j'ai composé des chansons des fois une
fois tu mettes écoute d'un dieu n'est
pas remplie et que tout ne tourne pas à
mener jetez plus capable de l'entendre
type en tout mais comment tu fais pour
rester chez eux pendant 14 heures quand
tu fais des trucs comme ça il ya des
moments où tu sors de ta zone j'ai des
moments au dessus du change de zone mais
il ya des défauts de soi très lucide
mais d'autres footeux soit complètement
craqué d'entrée comme je dis yako
j'ai tourné tf1 et la soirée le var 12
heures du mans thé en terrasse dans une
arène de boxe chuter le coach puis après
comme on dit c'est la seule chose tu es
jeux télé faut que tu prononces parce
que c'est l'alcool fait que ça prononce
- mais justement sortir de l'hiver c'est
des projets tellement différent alors
changé de zone fait que ce hit and pop
soul ici à 8,7 un peu ce qui a fait une
petite marche petite épicerie vraiment
gros journée ça m'a aidé à 17 ans si je
me défonce la danse et une rapidité
d'exécution
autrement dit mettons jeux qui sortent
mais tant que tu réalises le tout et
travail tu mets ton jeu ton album le
tour d'honneur album tellement de
travail nouvelles orchestrations
pourquoi je me dis qu'il faut que tu
sois capable d'aller vite pour vraiment
vite on te dira en ayant vu les gens qui
fonctionnent moi j'ai un peu
chansonnette mon logiciel d'une façon
que j'ai un peu inventé mais faut
vraiment il faut vraiment que ça et vite
sinon ça me j'ai besoin qu'on passe à
côté d'un momentum choses prennent
beaucoup de temps qu'on réécoute puis il
ya beaucoup de banques comme ce mois ci
c'est le contrat sinon j'ai l'impression
c'est juste s'habituer à une tonne en
train de faire une toune écoute les
coûts c'est à dire quelque chose qui
était même pas sûr qu'ils aient fini
exemple la chercher à son tacle est
attaché à ce transfert sur tech donner
des titres en lettres majuscules sinon
j'ai l'impression que c'est comme moins
bon filon couche jamais la tonne parce
que je sais que je rentrais de suggérer
que jamais ok parce que quand je vois la
réouvrir le jeu vaut faire appeler le
premier exacte de la première tu es le
premier site web soit vraiment dans le
jeu de la vitesse lors des premières
t'es qui toi premier tech souvent voire
plus pour les autres aussi mais c'est un
myspace com j'écoute la première peut
essayer dispose pas toujours la première
dame c'est vraiment un état d'esprit
comme
cette religion la rapidité le spontané
spontanée et c'est alors que c'est la
44e le meilleur à manu plus tant à faire
bah j'ai dit ce que j'ai des histoires
déjà que c'est comme ça qu'ils
fonctionnent ça dépend vraiment de
chacun sait chaque réalisateur à sa
façon d'amener le monde a performé puis
c'est vraiment le plus vite possible
loto je veux faire tout c'est un jour
jean valence je fais ma mode turbo
à quel niveau mettant taxes et les
imperfections comme comme comme savoir
un objet artistique
par exemple j'étais des exemples de
l'histoire qu'on entend par exemple je
suis pas de frank zappa qui est en
studio tu rates une note une bonne
chance de te reprendre de radio 1 c'est
pas moi c'est comme même site à chanter
n'importe quoi ce titre je veux je peux
te remettre exactement à bonne place sur
youtube mais ce stade et rit ça dépend
de chacun ce qui veux moi je suis plus à
l'est que de la personne qui la pythie
soit genre quelqu'un qui veut qui veut
performer puis je ne prendrai pas la
tête qui était correct puis je vois la
rangée je vais me la laisser performé
ces cas vu martin dépendantes objets que
ses fils d'hélène mais ce ton dernier
album et une coupe des featurings est
amer et man mettons les défis comme la
sorbonne qui marient mais si maintenant
elle est arrivée avec la nouveauté qui
en fait la méthode de travail
telle est à 44 x ce qu'ils veulent ou
bien je me rappelle comment ça s'est
passé
je peux je peux arriver avec ma méthode
de travail
comme j'ai avec mon laptop en soient ici
on aime aussi
voici le tableau kloten qui équipe mais
le racing on est plus en mode comme moi
qui fais
zombies montre relativement de la même
façon je pense que l'epo de gens à
reprendre mais le fois non plus longue
comme un jeu bien on a bien connecté en
général puis armé jamais implantées
puissent aller comme jésus un jeu très
on était dans le garde-robe
il ya eu un moment où on n'allait rien
n'est perdu
le bourreau frère comment régler tous
les deux ont le comme mobilier de suite
plus on a cherché pendant trois ans on
ne jamais retrouver
je vais plus t'es quoi piquer ce qu'on
dit finalement mais qu'ils avaient perdu
nos mains la tête mais l'idée ou s'il en
impôts tech on avait juste idée plutôt
bien tous savaient comment j'en ai même
que si j'ai été trahi le dictaphone qui
comme l'application de base devrait
passer un certain nombre de gt gt trahi
passé un certain nombre d'attentions
peut disparaître
l'accès c'est pas des mp3 on s'est passé
où le nuage entendre des idées sortir
sur un album que je veux pas qu'ils
voudraient interpréter ce genre de mai
j'ai vu pris finalement l'application
dropbox qui va directement dans un
dossier mp3 dans doit boxer de garder
bonne idée mais ouais je suis vraiment
obsédé de l'idée je me rêvais dans la
nuit puis si je suis dans mon rêve ta
réponse
mais elles existent pas que je m'oblige
à me réveiller pour la halle à noter que
je sais que l'inventivité des notes
strelok 2 0
c'est fou ça c'est la zone chaque fois
est utilisé comme pas dans le film en
class40 et yeux s'ouvrent puis tout et
quand tu reprends conscience c'est clair
des fous tu veux te rendormir pour
poursuit un rêve d'y attirer les fans
purs et d'exactitude l'air pour
l'épicier
informations roland spiritus à partir
demandera quant à l'oral marche jeu là
dessus c'est ainsi je rêve là oui
ouais celle ci est fier d'annoncer une à
deux heures par jour
moi j'ai essayé de la faire le jeu
marnissi jeu mais bon j'ai pris ma cause
de vous mais c'est ses collants crise de
dette très vrai avec des églises des
chansons pis combien seront bien mettons
se rendre jusqu'à la concrétisation de
peut-être une chanson le clip tant
attendu tout le temps
l'instrumentation banon ça dépend de la
vision de fo s'étonnent de fausses et
qu'il faut casser tous deux les yeux
cela-dit président afin de le juke box
je pourrais le prends la peine d'aller
m'attriste ça devient compliqué dans
l'ordi des cessions j'aime mieux les
petits
j'ai développé le beatbox ya longtemps
j'essaie de faire des trucs ça ça
paraissait pas du tout alors dans ce but
la mode on ne peut plus être chaud je
pratique plus elle c'est rare layton
laisse d'équivalence en conquête pour le
nombre de kills jeu c'est normal aussi
une dose de chansons qui peut sortir de
quelqu'un dans la ville mais des
exemples avant de disparaître
je suis dans un centre cheikh logique
comme j'ai cependant la musique qui joue
tout ce qui est en rapport avec la
musique charge comme dans le je pense
famous qui dansent derrière des kops
sympa demain tu t'adaptes 1
mais tel quel j'aurais pu mettre le mémo
vocal comme fenton ou un trop grand cd
flash tous en même temps ça devra faire
une toune de météorites à soual il faut
je crois que j'ai déjà essayé de
calculer passe avant il faut mettre un
chiffre aux choses qui valent aussi de
l'argent qui était une tonne de
quelqu'un d'autre comme de a à z et une
tonne de moi se détournent plus rapide
de rappeler deux fois plus de baisse
en gros les grosses prod comme mon album
que je me sens comme compliquer la vie
volontairement c'est comme du quart
entre heures de travail et pas beaucoup
quand même pas ses 40 ans à une personne
les gens cités composent lettre qu'un
sosie forme si je fais pas ça il ya les
musiciens que les textes ouais c foot il
faut que tu accumules faut que se
multiplient par la norme de personnes
n'ont pas fait que c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup en fait vraiment un truc ça
vous voir la complexité et musicale en
plus et je peux quand même très content
des cessions mais donne à voir un est-il
vrai c'est fou dont la parole est quand
même satisfait ce genre de sa pas allé
jusqu'à l'espace fête fun fun voie de la
double la panne soit une harmonie de
l'adoption la pente juste l'écart qui
vient d'arriver c'est comme un d'ytrac
ce qui m'attend puis de base tu avais je
sais pas moi la musique un genre de 40
ça peut simplement t as en battant
général genre de 50 de vous jeter contre
au sol mais peut-on de 50 à 100 puis ces
temps ci on est dans le gard 25 hockey
plus vite plus spontané plus trois
éléments tomber le wapiti fausses oui
oui moi j'avais tendance à hyper
orchestré même dans le temps qu'on a
commencé dans la profonde c'était quand
même
il est justement orchestration sow puis
ces temps ci on est vraiment tombé sur
un groupe avant l'abandon mais aucun ne
sont exacts
la sphère le bâtiment gros lead vocal
qui a pas besoin est appuyé par quoi que
ce soit sans limite justement se donner
dans la classe c'est un peu ça la
philosophie l'impression il complique
cité métisse et quand même on se voit
beaucoup à gauche à droite là mais ça
change beaucoup
mais si y'a pas 45 me laisse assez
basses et c'est là c'est le stalles avis
le projet pays de change souvent très
inspirant moi c'est un peu ma deuxième
école de la petit mot sera tellement
changé le rap depuis depuis accrophone
j'ai appuyé
j'écoutais puce jetée ambiance une
grosse phase folklore qui pigent pendant
sept ans la dige comme arrêter faire
débit puis ceux qui choisissent tout
comme moi je suis plus trop ce que
j'arrive le lot rappelé toute la
nouvelle haïti les espèces de s'y jeter
d'âge chiche comme j'ai juste arrêté
dans le black moon le vieux new york
lubumbashi
ça existe encore mais c'est elle c'est
tellement travaillé une façon différente
pilot sport 3 ans j'écoute que durable
je retourne à l'école maintenant je
pense que le jeu les lol ça président le
juge tout ce qui est nettement devancé
le modèle dans les rapports le kiki qui
marche bien au québec en ce moment le
j'entends pas de bis qui me comble ce
trip et que les bidonvilles ou pas yves
vraiment incroyable dans ta j'avais
l'impression que critique dont on la
croyait pas beaucoup de monde qui sévit
depuis déjà l'impression d'être au top
de mon game le plus j'arrive justement
la nouvelle génération puis crissier des
producteurs mais vraiment le fabuleux
loin avec last five dès lors les églises
exhaure ya des génies du rap
y a rien en ville ou pas vraiment
vraiment se soucier vraiment c'est
vraiment un grand beatmaking
du québec qui en a d'autres avec la
spéciale mois pour moi le c'est un des
projets les plus intéressants que
j'entends du prodige avec les clés pour
jouer comme un martin voit flou un pied
avec la spa c'est vraiment son style le
bit génial je n'y puis au génie
quelqu'un comme toi que j'ai vu pendant
toutes ces années là où ou du moins que
vu la différence entente la messe la
naissance le lieu l'avant garde du rap
mais depuis la situation actuelle
qu'est ce qui crée cette espèce
déférence d'effervescence look qu'on
connaît maintenant le tient en ce moment
et des projets qui sont autant il y en a
quand les smarties soviétique s'est il
amusé quel monde écoute le plus vas-y
les raisons je pense que de la zone
logique
les gens de mon âge ont continué à
relativement active la wii connaissent
ça fait partie d'eux puis la savait que
ça commence tranquillement à faire la
moitié du monde qui existe
je suis entre 78 02 que exact j'ai 35
ans puis ça fait beaucoup de monde ce
qui tire de tout le monde d'après moi ça
fait juste beaucoup de monde à qui
beaucoup de monde l'élu zina rap faut
qui fournissent la demande est énorme
c'est ce qui remplit le plus les salles
de spectacle je pense je pense qu'on a
vu avec les francofolies qu'ils aient
disparu
elles sont les plus grosses scènes s'est
faite moi l'ailé mt l'us dollar
c'est ce rapport les radios commerciales
qui n'ont jamais compris que ce qui se
passe là mais tout le reste l'europe
comme tellement imposant ça c'est normal
que le nombre d'artistes l'intérêt porté
à ce et est énorme
on est vraiment tendre on les réussit
finalement m on pense moins nettement
dans le temps c'est le type de sujet de
rap le plus commun c'est réussir à
percer réussir aller à les convaincre
que le raf security qui convainc qui
déjà n'ont jamais su ce qu'ils vont
mourir ça fait ça comme ça mais c'est
une énorme toutes les générations après
moi ça fait partie d'eux vraiment bougé
j'ai réalisé à quel point le métier de
culte et joue avec les comités avec
amélie pis sa gang
puis on allait jouer il était passé au
cabinet gami c'était comme la partie des
moniteurs qui dit il ont tout de suite
c'est 19 pts profane de la charge de
faire un show ces vols et on peut enfin
la 106 le monde paye pas le fun pis si
le clerc marty pour ça que c'est immonde
qui très pratique est bon le voit dans
leur effectif on fait juste qu'espèce
cara black des petits bouts de têtu pas
sexe triste épilogue cette semaine son
viry fumay away sont virés complètement
mongol plomb faisait des petits bouts de
refrains de des lobbies pide annoncé
clairement le catch email leur tête
explosée mendy pau des musiques qu'on
aurait pu leur faire qui rit kiri mais
plus tu sais ça c'est que c'est le
croire de ça mais en plus ce style de
musique l'ops d'engouement que ça fait
mal ça fait des spectacles
c'est comparable à des shows de pangi
c'est le nouveau passer le niveau le
niveau d'intensité du public
une intensité du ch au plus d'intensité
de fréquence de musique de baisse de
rythme et de chaud répandant on a
atteint le niveau de dance c'est
optimale dans l'attitude aussi un peu
contre culture où je sais pas trop quoi
de ce qui est aimé ton vélo 15 à 20
heures la rébellion qui était par le
punk mais le season par le rappeler
c'est comme mélanger les choses rap
comme ça ouais le tranquillement il est
chaud drap ou quelqu'un s'est mis à les
bpm ont commencé à ralentir donc le
potentiel de sauter ça crée un monstre
la plus intense que tu peux aller voir
sauf des trucs de métal où je suis allé
je suis allé au show de larry kid à
l'impérial de deux ans au festival d'été
qui sait la soirée metallica sur les
plaines fait qu à l'impérial c'est une
croix de l'ordre des petites filles qui
qui était le stepper nécessairement
l'élu des métalleux les métallos
discipline puis f1 wheel of dead ops et
paris la foule en deux oui il ya 10 à
goran très prudent dans le noir chose de
moi j'étais là parce que c'est par la
foule monstre
tu arrêtes sur un break la tonne plus
j'ai déjà vu ce que faisait l'autre côté
approprié il parla parfois je l' ai vu
le youtube leur premier clip le trot
palestine arabe rouge et noir les gars
sont forts c'est ce genre de truc tu
adaptes les techniques de groucho métal
c'est cela m'empêche allemands comme tu
dis tout ça mélange dix mots quand
j'étais jeune moi j'ai fera plus vieux
aussi fatigué c'était comme les exemples
qui s'était vraiment je pense tout le
temps c'était comme se met et écouter du
pont coûte écouter du rap
3 aujourd'hui tout est beau être que
j'apprécie énormément et je vois le chez
les jeunes puis je prends à l'école
secondaire le m tout le monde s'est
habitué
aujourd'hui james est loin et bien eu
tout le monde comme leur propre identité
mais musicalement la musique qui n'est
pas dit que la population ça il est
inhalé eux c'est magnifique à vélo
franchement l'avancé ça c'est des gardes
de ces pôles même c'est bien mais pas
beaucoup
je suis le fameux reportage la tva pour
les pigs
québécomm korité comme kia cette
violence le loin qu'est-ce qui tombe ce
carton conviés par la cloud c'est cette
époque là les cédants le skate le skate
jouer à deux en un télescope il punk ça
allait quand même ensemble c'est aussi
risqué tupac l'émeute ont touché aux
deux noms baisse qui était à new york il
y avait vraiment des yo qui faisait du
skate une sorte on était vraiment sûr
seul mais en même temps j'aimais
beaucoup le fait que je peux comme c'est
là où je vais jouer dans l'est dans les
deux ans qui se touchaient pas tant que
ça bougeait et et benoît chelsea
rapidement général et l'eau c'est quoi
tu viens d'où je viens sans une fois
c'est trop loin du centre ouest il y
avait des tendances sur happy double
bonheur fou qui agit vraiment écouter un
album de rap pour me dire je m'assois
plus j'écoute ce pigeon je pense que de
kouassi genre my dog bull et surtout
cette fantaisie genre en 2008
ah ouais c'était au temps comme disait
le depuis c'est comme tu as compris le
groupe est très dépendant cham excellent
à moi même j'ai une phase où j'écoutais
plus dur que quand j'étais petit pied
ouais comme barnes à mes amis écouter
comme moi j'aime les refrains qui sont
chantés dans la tonne mais j'ai peur je
sais pas c est comme un espèce de
moments aux fonctions des paroles de
vieux l'intelligent maintenant ils sont
tellement sont tellement là dedans mais
il y avait vraiment quelque chose de mon
sujet une petite barrière de javel a
besoin dit finalement c'est j'ai fait ça
comme un an après l'abandon
et vraiment un step aujourd'hui c'est le
style de musique où est-ce qu'ils
puissent en effervescence pitié il ya
plus créatifs qui se passe j'ai
l'impression si le plus en évolution th
année c'est une course aussi c'est une
course commençait lui a faite c'est si
long à mettre à bas cette histoire comme
[Musique]
celle-là je la musique c'est en
constante évolution c'est encore jeune
au niveau qui existait depuis ça c'est
comme réinventer à mi chemin je suis
tellement là dedans ce moment c'est tout
ce que ces exemples des coups tu es ce
que tu écoute de la musique que quand
même dans les processus créatifs comme
ça tu écoutes tu planes musique pour
compte est inspiré ou ou ccd qrita
propres affaires dans un microcosme
apport à vos questions je suis jamais
dit quelqu'un qui écoutait beaucoup de
musique parce que je faisais beaucoup en
suisse romande et au besoin de belgacom
s'est ensuite j'ai mon nouveau conte du
logis comme maîtresse de son tout est
installé j'ai un projecteur avec je suis
dans une zone où la peau musique les
pour vous les propositions les nouveaux
albums jusqu'à brazeau un peu plus de
geeks des gains mais pas suffisamment
c'est pire on est comme une gagne a
speech et des tonnes de s'être entendues
sauce prend c'est des choses incroyables
qui sortent la quantité de musique que
j'écoute que je fais en ce moment est
très très très grosse c'est fou c'est
vraiment une gangue justement toute la
gang de accrophone à la clac 16 the
drama et réseaux vous avez créé un
environnement qui est tellement beau
puis propice à la création de répit tout
le monde se tire vers le haut le thé
c'est vraiment une chance incroyable que
vous avez de cette religion là on a un
groupe de six personnes qui est ses taux
à six personnes alors ferme puis on n'a
jamais eu de drogue
si tout ça monte tranquillement pire
espèce de respect mutuel
avec d'énormes différences au sein de ce
groupe on va l'aider des choses que les
autres groupes on voi on les voit aller
on musicalement ils vont se planter dans
la vie tu peux pas tu peux pas jouer la
rock star puis chaque plat une fille du
monde et ça ça va finir sa bosse faut
que tu entres eux tiennent là une espèce
de sagesse pour 10
les gars sont vraiment sage dans la zone
rouge
c'est vraiment un entretien de c'est pas
la coach du député sortie du show non
c'est ça c'est vraiment le contraire de
ce soir là d'une fine croûte pour
réaliser parce qu'il faut être couché je
pense qu'on ne devrait en faire des
valeurs historiquement le gag mais cette
fois ça marche
ouais là la cabane à sucre
[Rires]
c'est un très bon vidéo c'est ma la
radiologie on commence tous fidélité
avec les drones qui sait que sniper mais
c'est il ya un espèce d une espèce de
mythe et geeti il ya une espèce d'euros
mythique autour de la clair que je
trouve qu'ils vraiment intéressant parce
que tout ce qui tout ce qui créa pour la
musique
même la musique s'y est comme un flou
entre entre le l'humoristique pileux
l'artistique puis même dans les dents
vous dans vos personnages dans ce que
vous dégagez il ya aussi un peu cette
dichotomie le way qui fait que c'est du
sud parisien l'a clairement même temps
qui s'écoule ceux qui le kilo sans allen
exact qui garde le feu c'est pire que
prévu
c'est ça qui est ça nous tous qui nous
c'est nous tous qui nous allume en fait
cette vidéo là ça nous allume byron ce
projet leur vie je pense que les gens
ils sentent qu'ils sentent que c'est
vrai chacun justement une petite ligne
dans le monde et on est des gens qui me
colle énormément penser que les insight
sur des insa quelqu'un qui serait avec
nous dans l'aval
ça va falloir un chouille si tu
comprends vraiment pas grand chose de ce
qui se passe puisque c'est que des
inside du même mois le petit je me bats
pour mon fils un certain laps de temps
le ton dans l'ouest je reviens et
puisque l'italien devra purger
si tu peux pas lâcher à la clac peu pour
revenir un an plus tard puis soir ont
perdu aussi le rythme dans le show il
n'y a pas de pratique si on fait
tellement de choses notamment une
connexion puis je me sentirais comme
complètement déconnecté le samedi ça
m'est déjà revisité cheval de troie
choletais c'est comme un sport assez
peas socialement aussi évoqué un univers
complètement avoue tes pieds on avait la
même discussion avec fou qui justement
si fou qui fait un peu ça aussi écrit et
créé un lexique créé des mots et sabaoui
qu'un mouvement qui fait que les fans se
sentent bien qu'ils se mettent à
comprendre les hangars s'engager il
non ça c'est ça qui fidélise aussi un
auditoire site de qom se sentir un peu
penser à se concrétiser comme ça c'est
bamba triste parce que vous êtes vous le
faites pas dans un but de dire qu'ils
ont fait mais les résultats que ça crie
ça fait qu'il ait nous aussi on a des
mains suffit lors de l'audience
jusqu'ici quand on fait une tournée
c'était que mouawad
ils connaissent layton deuxième tournée
partout en france dans des trous le de
manquer j'ai fait trois heures de route
depuis connaissent 4,99 l'album
c'est fou waouh fou qui nous a raconté
une histoire aussi de quitter achevée à
la cloche postes en suisse où il y avait
des suisses ici entre que qui était la
bonne c'est là bas qu'ils aient été
darwin top il ya deux gars qui sort du
suisse et pillent la [ __ ] c'est bon
mais je compris ce qu'ils disent et pi
qui dit dgo je québécois comprend pas
vraiment ce samedi après ce qu'ils
mettent à profit les voiliers oh [ __ ]
la famille je suis content la famille
[ __ ] c'est la famille c'est ça le but
ça serait prévu ce genre ont crié la
famille dans la famille l'a fait mais ça
ça va dans notre notre religion le dit
justement le cg comme elle a rejeté une
pierre trois coups le système c'est ça
ça promouvoir notre nos principes de
base puis les gens peuvent crier un de
façon hyper simple c'est le top de
toutes les accents ethniques et des
femmes familiale eux deux dans la khl
action qui oppose enfants mais tout le
reste on est on est rendu au tas dans
frank de paiement que de vrais inquiet
quant à moi parce qu'on est comme 7
il y en a un qui est à toronto depuis ce
comme lui qui a inventé la club coke
écrit un billet simple et halak la pitié
je veux vraiment à droite puis à ken sur
le il ya une coupe de tonnes alors dit
et de leur premier album
ok lui parti fonder une famille a
tronqué ou sa blonde est de là-bas puis
quand on lui on essaie depuis sept
enfants non je pense qu'on évite la
progéniture est rendu voilà que les
enfants vont repartir le bnb le second
se maintient
qu'est-ce qu'on débranche différence
d'âge devient un temps pluvieux mais
dans la khl a aussi une fille samantha
comme française j'ai pas très bon dans
les orages le même de mes meilleurs amis
et qu'ils plus jeunes c'est celle de nos
villes ou peur non pas mal à ma mère je
me sens bien et j'ai l'air d'un idiot
soit comédiens on est tellement là moi
c'est les dates de faille était le plus
jeune c'est watts
c'est le plus vieux parce que c'est la
dose gros seins mais en même temps les
maturités
chacun son style d'arges à mal par ce
parlement tant que je veux aller dans
l'ouest
j'ai comme arrêter les shows de mon
album de mon projet solo
ok pour te concentrer sur la partie web
oui oui vraiment puis aussi si je bloque
un show de deux mois tu es je peux pas
prêtre l'a probablement être mieux non
en fait c'est ça je me suis donné la
liberté de pouvoir être pour voyager
plus cette année fait car c'est un peu
le boss de booking ça fait ce que ça
fait là c'est sûr que l'album amont il
veut jeter moins présent c'était une
année plus difficile comme je disais
tout à l'heure les grands piliers ont
bougé le terrain à la classe je peux ne
pas être le pendant les spectacles ont
certes on a déjà fait un show on était
trop à rester poli 3e appel plus des
genres mois ville où peur et me semble
mais le et ça marche
je l'aï vu s'en sont pris je sais même
plus ce qu'on a fait
voilà là j'avoue que c'est rendu dans la
clause il ya des contrôles il faut
quelqu'un des membres soit le sien
c'est même moi qui ai un peu moins
présent vocalement avec les trucs de
série et il ya du monde sont en mode de
jeu lui il faut que sois lot comme
important puis messi fait quand même
partie des l'image n'a pu aussi démenti
mme losier pas c'est quelqu'un qui a des
gros joueurs comme commune game il ya
des gens qui comptent plus de points le
gua défensif haulotte m'étonne
t'as pas de tabac demeure sous
concession et le fait qu socialiste s
amène de quoi au choix je me sens un peu
transformer en animateur physique
je n'aime pas vraiment et j'avais
beaucoup animé d'accrophone solo mais le
cheval comme jamais je suis là
physiquement c'est chaque entrée du
mystère qui n'a pas fait la même chose
que j'avais pu que j'avais en moi avec
des outils comme la tension en général
si on a fait un dj set à la fin du
dernier show à winnipeg
j'étais genre les gueux qui est fait
lever tout le monde puis samassa va
faire développer des skieuses de de
danse d'animation de physique de borisov
il comptait tantôt justement aussi que
ta performance de danse d'en faire ça
j'ai touché un service de l'animation
physique que j'ai fais un choix sûr
parce qu'ils donnent tout le moins
d'être de string avec des chaps mais
c'est normal c'est tout à fait normal
je vais t'avouer que j'ai pu écouter ça
sert pas mais hier soir j'allais voir
cette face au losc il fallait que je
voie 7,5 à y avait quelque chose de
vraiment dit ça serait cool
potentiellement plus fous qui demandent
les droits puis ce jeu le gifler sa
sauce quand j'ai vu quand j'ai vu arnold
en terminator qui paient les lunettes du
gafi sortie du bar avec le paillasson
rogen snapap les partants moto comme la
meilleure de tous les temps des copains
peureux vécu ce moment là je dis non de
façon métier comme au cinéma pareil
ouais ouais ce qui m'attend tapas forme
en fait tous cryptée lequel est pas
cachée tpiy le dubai tandis go c'est moi
puis le
chorégraphe qui l'aï inventé qui se
passe vraiment vite en plus un
si je faisais les mouches sur lui parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps de sicile en cas
de crash mardi par m a dit que je notais
tous les maux ah ouais tous les moments
là je vais répéter comme techniquement
puis je sais comment ça va tourner assez
rapide
ce genre de 5000 et plein de vue médical
mais en même temps puis à cinq fois
celle ci fais pas ça dix fois huit
heures du matin qu'une coupe de madame
sont un peu des vrais fans de
saint-maixent 7 heures du matin des
barrages
madame devant qui titre en une danse que
le footsie cas poil garde le titre pop
ce titre soit était vraiment dans le ton
dans le rôle 63 comme savidan le matin
et c'est pas une goutte d'alcool
des enragés c'est parce que j'ai le
droit de zeropoint je me marre de cette
autre travail l'appui fallait pas dire
ça où je suis je pense que c'est madame
le on ne connecte entre si c'est des
fois il ya des acteurs tu parles d'un
rôle qu'ils ont fait
puis il s'en rappelle moyens parce qu'il
était le personnage complètement
laitiers tout est tellement dans la zone
croissance
c'est quand même pu relier vraiment
utile moi j'espère moi ce qu'on m'a
donné à date c'est comme un peu moi la
mesure où ce qui est plus facile à jouer
quand pas d'expérience je joue un peu
moi qui aie mais je veux dire tu étais
dessus mettant fin je me rappelles tu es
tu capable de ne pas penser au cam ne
pas penser à la situation puis juste
d'être toi qui dans les deux cas ça va
des enfants
certaines scènes aller mieux que
d'autres le social est aussi le manque
d'expérience puis si on est vraiment
dans des situations très dans un cadre
de porte d'un appartement en intimité
avec le sait le même plateau le teint
c'est sûr que tu te mets à penser pas
mal plus socam pjak est ce que ça donne
darnaud dans la cage s'était
complètement dans une zone jeu mais
c'est l'âme le manque d'expérience fait
que tu peux comme instable n'est pas
régulier peut être comme super bon puis
comme support proche d'un très petit
louis gasset de faux prendre le plus
d'expérience possible c'est bien arrivé
plus régulier sur le plateau puis sur
une avenue
l'acting comme tu disais au début ce
podcast une avenue que tu veux explorer
plus pas mal ou ben je lui donnais plus
de chance parce que j'ai l'impression
que j'ai connus de 0 2 me dont 3 puis
j'avais envie d'avoir à me prouver à moi
même que j'ai pu aller au bout de sa
puis de voir si vraiment gic-g trappe et
il était dans un rôle plus peut-être
présent plus différent aussi
rocchi poney serment mwami dans un
contexte qui me ressemble ça me fait
rire et ça ça m'a toujours fait rue je
pense tout le monde un petit si on
regarde les faits une tournée comme si
c'était moi qui faisais ça c'est pas que
je fais que je fais comme juste réaliser
ce fantasme le quai tout le monde traîne
lorsque je pense à suivre une question
délicate
libre à toi de d'aller sur ces terrains
ou non mais est-ce que l'ambiance était
aussi lourde qui qu'on le dit mettons
sur le plateau soit l'autre sens vers la
zone du ch passe sur le cheval sympa
quand même
quand même moi ça va par expérience que
c'est comme ça ce milieu là c'est simple
un royaume
mais non puis après sa deuxième saison
et ont changé derrière de galles
toute l'équipe m'a légué par cool même
le real d'une certaine façon je suis lot
sur le premier épisode seulement puis là
j'ai eu une journée ou deux de tournage
bien c'est simple comme j'ai besoin de
temps même pas dans la même zone dans la
musique nombreux lacs des méthodes tut
yves directement témoin des trucs genre
vraiment inacceptable tant de la porte
du premier soit questionnable
c'est le jugement qui me regarde je sais
pas mais pour moi il ya des choses qui
se faisait pas métier je vois ça tous
les jours dans tous les milieux pire il
ya des gens vraiment plus intense que
d'autres selon les lois de 6,7 pas le
droit aux hommages
je suis moi mais je pense que témoin et
même et ben et puis c'est tant mieux
pour moi
comme il ya des gens qui file je
comprends ton tard est censée dépasser
c'est correct c'est pour revenir à ce
que tu disais de la lourdeur sur un
plateau quand c'est ta première
expérience pilote qui n'est pas
souhaitée c'est quoi blues the one
missed call le film la vida d'elle la
vida d'elle en français puis dans sa
gamme une espèce de synthèse
de sexe lesbien pis j'ai pas vu non
vraiment c'est une histoire d'un couple
est en fait qu blesse bien ou lesbienne
un couple de lesbiennes comme le
réalisateur a vraiment insisté sur sur
cette [ __ ] ils l'ont appris plusieurs
fois puis ajoutez longtemps puis les
fesses deux actrices un peu une nouvelle
dans un sens d'ailleurs le pot célia
aussi doux que sa peine il ya une des
deux qui est une recrue pilote chez
canadien qui sortit en théâtre en ayant
comme cinq ans parlait en fait le savez
pas encore ce avait pas de sens et le
cirque était qui arrivait sur le milieu
comme témoigne en disant moi je pensais
c'était comme l'école
ben oui pensez que c'est comme ça que ça
faisait l'acting vite tout le monde sur
le plateau comme les gens pour leur job
même si au moins de commentaires
c'est un milieu qui les jobs pleuvent
paul metella s'est cette fois ci c'est
au dessus
des fois c'est comme pour le bien des
tic ya une tension puis quand même
souvent un petit peu plus loin sa peine
pour les besoins et les maximes de
stanley kubrick qui reprenait les textes
à manger les cinq ans des centaines de
fois qu'ils étaient vraiment à rouler
sur les sièges parce que ça peut être
bon j'ai quand même c'est un peu ça le
style qui certainement ont pu ces jeux
c'est moins agréable
je sais pas si c'est maya aussi je pense
que vaut mieux peut-être aller dans la
zone que j'ai dit spontanée tantôt avec
une plaque de voir moi c'est savoir le
vidéoclip le on faisait comme 40 t il
vraiment nécessaire
tu as maintenant aujourd'hui soit on en
fait une ou deux puis quand la gauche
sait où ils sont en revanche les gars
savent ce qu'ils font devant c'est bien
mieux que ça aille plus vite que ce soit
plus relax sissoko à mon avis c'est pas
en signant puis en étant et ans que ça
servant sommaire même si c'est ton style
on pourrait rompre et le camp 13e lanta
on voit maintenant moi qui fais la
musique qui est venu ici à cette méthode
de travail j'ai l'impression qu'ils
avaient rapide aux vidéos sa finale est
revenue ici
moi je fais mon album en huit jours
ouais mais c'est ce qui fait notre l'ère
du laptop est tellement faire ça chez
vous le plus besoin d'avoir d'être
préparée dans un studio avec mais on
discute comme choisi pour investisseurs
tellement moins l'eau le niveau de
créativité de la densité est
complètement prend plus de risques si
c'est pas sûr fois king analogue sa cote
oui ça que ça partait y fait tout ce que
tu veux
ouais t'es vu ça te plus de musique qui
travaillait et affable sortir un projet
oui c'est bon de suite quand c'est moi
et s'est plusieurs fois effectivement
annoncé c'est vraiment ce que j'avais un
gros studio avant quand même d'europe le
guide que le filage philippides j'ai
dans mon coin de gym et rideaux doit
d'oublier le temps de théâtre puis on
ouvre on ferme sa laptop de 15 à 100
puis souvent j'utilise ma politesse de
son nom est juste écouteurs ça me fait
même chiite laïque et ma carte de son
jeu se complique ont plié la carte de
son j'aime tellement ça quand je prends
la toge déplogue toujours dans mon livre
je sais que mes écouteurs c'est là que
ça se passe
minimaliste comme dans un sac à dos je
pourrais travailler si on voyage
c'est ça la magie le mauvais le mot vers
marjah était je suis par quoi c'est un
lent move sur l'embout l'onl inquiète
vendredi
j'ai toujours été dans le milieu de la
musique c'est juste seulement cette job
l'appui elle est tout le temps là
montréal puis j'ai fait des allers
retours que j'ai fait déjouer apporter
mon fils à l'école jean marc morial je
reviens à chercher à l'école libre quand
même souvent c'est comme si ces bâches
devenu un peu accro à son gps à partir
de sa route le toit le jeu par pub c'est
un peu déstabilisant mais en bout de
ligne c'est comme un move que je devais
au moins essayer parce que d'être tout
le temps à travailler à montréal
puis lui étant dans l'ouest comme le
moment de dhr ce mois ci chez les godard
à clarens majeure partie en ce moment on
a toujours été plaide pas mal égal
québec montréal ça change de personnes
oui mais le tout est là genk sont plus à
québec mais la majeure partie de mes
amis sont à montréal gimont et le ça se
passe bien mais dans l'imaginaire de
tout c'est ce projet ces projets là il
ya quand même la ville de québec
c'est un peu un deuil de délaisser cette
ville
non non non
d'abord j'y retourne régulièrement puis
il ya le deuil du 10 36 9 qui est qui ça
a été ça a été une énorme époque je
pense et de l'adolescence ailleurs 21-25
colloque d'un salaire
ouais c'est ça aussi je suis comme seul
l'amour qu'on dit ou fait que selongey
avait du monde par la musique mais c'est
après la fin de ma vie
seul c'est vraiment spécial chez un
chien go vraiment de gagner je me
réveille à quelqu'un il ya plusieurs
personnes nous j'adore ce green album
qui a été fait aux 10 36 j'ai pas
compris d'albums j'ai présenté une norme
énormément gros studios du servage et
hop culturel incroyable t'imagines si ce
temps les soldats québec comme enquiller
un groupe il y a un physique ça je te
file j'ai déjà demandé une subvention
pour le studio
puis ils me l'ont pas ils n'ont pas
accepté jeudi sa décision maintenant est
ce que parce qu'ils savaient de quoi que
j'en retire à toute humilité on a créé
un studio ben correct
la cellule musical qui s'est passé là
pour la ville de québec
ça méritait vraiment totalement alors de
trouver d'autres façons de subventionner
là bas on a donné à la ville de québec
pine trail swing tonia qui parlait
justement de systèmes systems genre de
fierté une genre de cellules qui
s'écoule en parlait souvent la rivalité
montréal québec nous dans la première
entrevue c'était tout le temps sur le
sujet dans ton d'accrophone puis c'est
pourquoi c'est cool c'est cool québec
mais c'est ça le gros village mais moi
on était tellement au centre ville de
québec qui ont un quartier c'est au
milieu c'est ça puis on a grandi dans
les courbes qui sont comme juste à côté
et pis si c'est un peu un monde à part
mais c'est vraiment au centre la ville
de québec depuis 15 mois un accent
différent on est bien on a des gars du
centre de secours comment tu fais pour
mon studio durcissent et c'est déjà
parti on a envahi le bloc enfin qui vous
avez pris le bloc complet au oui
monsieur ling qui était le propriétaire
puis c'est tellement un bloc incroyable
ces coins phrase en plus moi j la
géologie là j'ai mon ami loges et l'ag
tom que crée rendu les quatre
appartements neufs en pole c'était comme
un espèce de l'espèce de ruches le dire
plus le temps passait les années passent
et puis c'est moi qui étais comme est
passé de la marijuana fab cela les
parties à côté pitt et sa com fait seul
puis ça s'est mis a dégénéré d'un côté
j'avais comme les deux à part d'en haut
moi j'étais vraiment relax pis si 36 et
comme démanteler un peu tout seul mais
que le bloc a été vendu 1 autres
proprios puis elle puis lui paul lui
c'est un peu un mode toulon doit surtout
sinon qu'est éventuellement on vers
l'est entre jean-pierre encore le pied
dans 10 36 soit dix ans à venir un jour
j'ai appuyé des dalles
j'ai comme techniquement une chambre
quai à qui l'appartement 4 c'est fini je
fais des dons mais je lâche le bout de
piles un acte orgueil il ya grandi dans
un environnement web le plan colombie
n'est pas en avait deux on avait deux
colloques puis moi c'est ça que j'aime
c'est la commune et oui j'aimerais de
imagine d'être entouré de tous ses fils
evan écoles waldorf le quai comme une
école alternative complètement fly et
quittent ils font ils pensent l'année à
dessiner des projets collectifs à faire
des choses dans la forêt c'est extra il
vous en venez à l'amiable joie
d'inscrire où tout commence bien qui
peut s'activer une école borders qui est
complètement dans l'ouest soit de chasse
comme quatre heures d'auto par journal
via l'ena dans le chef fait que mme
chartrand évalué seul c'est un peu un
stress de placement dans la ville des
éléments à suivre toujours en avoir
robles comme le convainquit parce que
manquant pas cette école quelque chose
doté d'antennes ici ouais là tout le
plateau annoncé les anglais les anglais
ont des accords anglaise morial je sais
pas parce qu'elle a de l'ouest a lancé
qu'il se règle au fun sont sur ce genre
de truc lé d'accueil et qu'une
communauté anglophone à bali où est-ce
qu'ils ont créé une école s'appelle la
queen's school puis ce genre ce genre
d'affaires le petit voleur c'est comme
c'est le montant un peu ce qu'ils
veulent l'alternative plus tard il a
beau jour qui tue à lire et à écrire ce
qui peut faire du parec oui c'est un
processus celui venant en mode à
apprendre l'anglais comme fo et puis ils
vont triper mélangé à changer d'air
mélangée avec sa mère mais c'est un
processus qui disent qu'il faut petit
support de leurs petits gardons
professeur dos contenant la même je suis
en bout de ligne le plus de résultats
mais isoler une année se disent mal mais
c'est le concept est vraiment bon jour
j'y crois absolument puis moi c'est pas
ça existait dans mon temps mais je teste
est tellement un mauvais élève cgt comme
considéré comme dans les tannants la cgt
comme celui punis mais j'étais
aucunement d'un an j'étais juste paul
ouais parce que ce qu'on me faisait face
pour moi c'était suite le décor dit
quelque chose d'important je partais
c'est comme le mood placer les attrape
dans des dix ont des projets jamais mon
fils il appuie t'entraînes pour écouter
lotus s'est complètement captivant
c'est ce qui avait fallu que j'allais
prendre la main me soit en même temps
dont je vous mettais première c'est moi
mettons les trucs alternatifs comme ce
fut tout d'abord sceptique parce que
parce que le système qu en est il est
quand même été réfléchi pensé par du
monde qui savent plus ce qu'ils font
mais j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui les
enfants ayant besoin d'être plus
stimulée petits grandissent avec des
tablettes ou les enfants mais qui font
que ça a été pensée honnêtement
c'est un peu des gens qui faisaient leur
job en france ces choses sales are d'un
système gaieté qui a été un peu s'ils se
sont un peu perdus il n'y avait pas de
science qui n'avait que le thé les
petites gueules qui ont besoin de bouger
depuis les évidences le choc ça s'est
transformé puis parce que je crois
vraiment plus aux écoles alternatives
sans avoir étudié la question puisqu'il
faut six machines pour certaines
personnes
ma blonde à la fête montessori ce type
d'école j'essaie possible collaboration
primaire qui avait pas de clans
maintenant vous savez les niveaux au sco
les niveaux et eric on peut mélanger
ouest un peu sonné c'était vraiment je
pense tu avais des tâches afin de
rentrer semaine nous attend journée mais
ça de deadline précis mais ça n'est pas
fini tauch défend d'avoir une semaine
terrain mais c'est comme si j'arrête un
travail si j'entends travailler de façon
plus autonome et il n'y a pas de bureau
tu prennes un peu comme tu veux toi moi
tout ce qui en plus des cadres et de ce
qu'ils ont créé
comme chez moi j'ai tellement appris à
parler à l'heure avec un arrêté quand
j'ai arrêté
au minimum sa gourde a du talent et un
mois au cégep qu'est l'eau tellement
vinci peut pas marcher tac tac au tac
on a tout de suite commencé à faire des
shows de microphones j'ai vraiment
arrêté après souvent la même que je
pense jamais comme tous les français
j'ai fait une année juste pour le
français à l'école aux adultes gelé
comme passer en mode cruz est la preuve
de ce que la critique mais on continue à
apprendre après mais je suis un cas
d'école depuis mon expérience en général
a tellement été c'était l'horreur le nom
mais je te dis même team joueront en géo
lanata deuxième compétition et en sport
études puis moi je me suis rendu jusqu'à
l'université puis en train dé finaliste
ma maîtrise mais si c'était pas la
natation puis du support études puis du
sport universitaire fête du sport
collégial sport universitaire motivé que
jamais j'aurais arrêté ma mère pour en
témoigner j'aurais arrêté après seconde
bosser ça te fait et j'avais aucune
motivation à continuer cole joue est ce
tellement chien j'aimais vraiment pas si
gentil je me levais le matin ça me
tentait pas aller à reculons tout le
temps sauf cabeza sauf que moi j'avais
s'affiche avec à l'université si tu es
quand marc que tout le monde disait
c'était comme la meilleure notation puis
- ses hôtels plus le fun fait que c'est
comme ce qui me motive à rester en
disant j'aime tellement la natation je
profiterai pas de la meilleure notation
effectivement au final j'y mets
qu'artiste pas tout le monde que moi je
voudrais me propose rien
il lui avait des écoles de musiques
métisses j'étais comme tout le monde
quitte à l'elysée dit pollock t'apprend
à face à son nom s'accorderait pop et un
orienteur nancy d'aller à l'école très
bas ce matin à prendre le logiciel
réticences automatique puis finalement
c'est ça que je fais mais je peux aller
loin mais
continuez à la l'école puis justement il
ya des genres de programmes optimale
dans le truc qui te passionne mais ça
fait un bon side the talented en musique
puis je serai pas musique aujourd'hui
j'étais parti dans musique ouais mais ça
ça n'est pas aussi pour qui pour qui
tout être il ya des gens vraiment qui
sont ultra autodidacte
ouais c'est ça qui te kiffe j'te fais en
révolte et j'aime pas ça savoir les
accords j'ai l'impression que le savoir
ça trahit quelque chose mais c'est aussi
moi je tenais à ce jour je connais pas
le siffler lot
ouvrez j'écoute la musique qui est ça me
fait capoter mais ça c'est qu'elle
aurait épuisé j'ai dit à mon père que
c'est même toute ma famille sont en
musique le pied j'ai dit je devrais
dessus cette conversation épique je
devrais dessus comme la apprendre
finalement teri tout ce que j'ai acquis
tout ce que j'ai pu créer moi-même et f
non tu vois comme perdre une certaine
magie piges
c'est ça ne nuit pas du tout le jeu sort
que j'arrive ce que je disais à
quelqu'un que je sache où j'ai pas
besoin de sang humain dans ce que tu as
fait le bon choix
ouais c'est quoi les écoles langage qui
tu parles avec les musiciens car des
tensions dont des notes des matchs les
champs on se chante les notes mais c'est
maintenant je sais qu'un auto tune
houtman gamme pourquoi la personne
chante ça fait partout c'est une arrêt
absolu lors la définition de l'absolu
c'est comme tu me dises charente antonov
je suis sur le bon temps mais quand un
ennemi mais s'est passé quand il me fait
peur à moi et helton qui toi devant ton
tout le temps non non non mais j'ai
vraiment de ré pour être les pour
trouver les harmonies pour savoir ce qui
marche marche pas bien créativité mais
j'ai vu un gars qui avaient leur est
absolu c'est moi j'avais jamais je
n'avais jamais vu ça un peu ici j'ai
l'arrêt absolu au corps ouais de deux mi
temps je t'aime pardon j'ai fait ma tête
j'avais à l'époque moi c'était un tour
de magie et lui avais absolument leur
est absolument si j'en sais quelque
chose qui existe chez lui aux deux
mi-temps le seco maïs et déjà c'est déjà
génial
le staff on sait même pas si celui petit
c'est en train d'opérer ici c'est pas
tout à fait tort mais ça peut devenir
t'avoir fois coeur parce que le temps en
temps des notes partout noté mais c'est
ça je sais pas quel point ouais il faut
faire par axa goss et george que oui je
sais pas quel point c'est un avantage
par exemple richard
je suppose que oui peut-être le profil
que oui mais c'est pas parce que tu te
le rêve celui qui est nécessairement et
génie de la musique alors ce sera pas de
lien c'est beau comme chez elle
tentant de tout tu dois savoir c'est
quoi les accords si tu dois t'en maudens
est tous d'accord là mais moi je pense
jamais à cette non j'aime ça pas y
penser
j'ai comme un filet grâce à cet accord
le meeddat c'est toi je peux le
reproduire
si je veux mais j'essaie pour s'imposer
que le plus possible comme un outil
temps normal j'en suis reconnaissant de
fait plutôt que c'est quoi les
mécanismes de la misère pop rock soul
comme sa pop mais au niveau des
arrangements mais pas les accords ne pas
savoir les accords streep
mais si je pense activement si mettons
toujours fous je répète que la tonne
d'infos là je refoule apprennent en
l'écoutant je peux savoir c'est que les
accords mettant dans l'analyse et ce
n'est pas faux que les gens aient
nécessairement tout en foutent là dessus
parce que je ne suis écouté de la
musique c'est réussi et qui écoute juste
la musique de muse issing même presque
le type vraiment de la musique est
impressionnant techniquement qui va
redécouvrir ce nom c'est moi la musique
post j'écoute les paroles ou si j'écoute
l'émotion que ça me procure t il faut il
faut j'essaie d'écouter comme soit comme
un public normal ou comme un réalisateur
qui pense à toutes les balises à ceux de
la zone car tu comprends pas ce que tu
écoutes le même c'était un gars qui fait
de rased toutes ces affaires le moi
j'aime tellement seul je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est bon c'est pas ma place
ahmed el hafi a chante comme mal le
score ça semble mauvais mais c'est
complètement magique
j'essaie de j'essaie de comprendre le
plus pour le stif
c'est ça qui comme colette maïs sur des
tonneaux avant j'ai décidé à musique
c'est de vouloir faire des choses bonnes
dilletante et puis bah c'est soit une
longueur parfaite
c'est vraiment pas nécessairement tous
temps les chanteurs les plus techniques
associées à la neige à la magie vraiment
comme youtube se situe bien j'allais
dans les louis d'or
la pêche à la magie et probablement
l'outil le plus efficace pour comme
faire de la bonne musique c'est comme
des fois je me donne sur l'atome ne
traîne pas j'attends des excuses par un
moment qui a croisé un autre moment
étrange mais dans tout ça c'est là c'est
l'ultime cela prouvera parole mais je
vois toujours un petit peu à la page
peut laisser une suite de saynètes
jouées pendant le mondial comme le
centre tendu que c'est le bon même s'il
vient de youtube en pétrole
on est on est plus lol je remettais au
mastering ça va finalement tous au
départ et puis est-ce que ce qui mixte
et thoune août était réaliste et fmx et
il ya de ça le mec ce aussi comme dans
la définition de cas de s'il ya un
artiste
maintenant le monde pop lors tout seul
qui crient leur bosse le mix maintenant
et comme fait un peu sur le spot dans
mois peu de logiciels j'ai déjà un prix
mastering normes y voit tout et déjà
commenté m j'ai tout fait matin plaît le
mix créatif et le fameux saut je la
revois je sais mon doudou avec qui je
travaille depuis le début le tome
lapointe qui lui va corriger comme un
peu chiant des fois parce que de faucher
dans les mecs if all créatif mallet
battre au liban trop gros je lui fais
juste corrigé corrigé 4g j'appelle ça le
mec ce correctif
puis après seuls mecs collective se fait
souvent en un temps avec le mastering
août une baisse le volume tu la vois
masteriser dans des machines qui pue
personne croit finalement leur style
ailleurs game länder cette image passe
connaissez sap ans la dame est atone
puis
bref c'est une des algorithmes c'est
déjà mieux de trois mois
mais c'est son prénom tu connais de la
gauche de mme nached brioche aurillac et
c'est lui il y avait en fait son
doctorat au mastering lurcel aval que le
tir à malley le plus grand guide
mastering
puis une fois jeté les chez eux puis il
y avait travaillé sur de tourner pour ma
blonde il y en a qui fait masterisé par
l'un d'eux puis jamais montrées sous pli
et l'écouté ce non non non non il ya
genre larcher son doctorat au pied
dimanche 2 mai aps une seconde de ma vie
dans le mastering
à ce moment là je pense que c'était une
époque là j'ai vu le moment où il a
[Rires]
donné des conférences au journal l audio
puis le mastering qui jardine corps à la
science la science comme fait non
georges en faire autre chose à ma vie
qui est déjà son projet manager mais
mettrait pas autant d'importance dans
développe des bureaux puis un autre pour
des masses n'ont pas vraiment d'une
autre époque en paient programme cher
puis on est dans un studio complètement
parfait des caisses de son temps après
avant après ce genre de gourou ya une
partie et au tehrik dans la qualité
audio la manne et les monde qui vient
moi j'ai complètement comment on
consomme en plus complètement c'est que
c'est tellement loin dans la liste des
priorités des choses importantes
ces passifs une bonne tendance tactique
et qu'est-ce que tu transmets ckoi
l'émotion échos qui se passe mais pitié
après ceux qui pètent et qualité audio
mis en forme et c'est ça qui est
rampante et moi j'aime la musique qui
sonne
voir je tripe là dessus mais quand je
sais c'est sale c'est c'est là dessus
très sérieuses et moi j'ai des rideaux
qui font le 6 ou pis hier les filles
étaient ceux d'ivan j'étais quand tu vas
parler on l'entendre on s'en fout séance
ça fait partie des bruits ambiants
on s'en fout de touche vraiment dans le
retour du balancier une époque où
j'étais quand même je cale sur le
attention aux songes acheter dit mme
briand j'avais acheté 2 créant pas 1500
pieds à chaque pour ploguer en stéréo la
table tournante pour simple idée venait
je repense à ce jeu c'est le retour du
balancier j'en ai plus rien à faute de
la qualité puis on est fan on avait des
fans aussi humaine c'est fou ce que plus
besoin de moi j'avais écouté les fous
furieux avait sorti l'album wasting
light soit ce que l'oeil they come on
enregistrera en analogue qui sur des
thèmes toute l'équipe il y avait la
recommandation de commun écouter leurs
albums pour être capable de d'abord
essayer de l'aider parce qu'ils aiment
copie
mais comme les autres il faudrait comme
un trip pour disaient vous pouvez
enregistrer vous pouvez écouter sur
votre ipod dont 100 cols et les tonnes
vont être bonnes mais si vous voulez
voir la différence plaie avec un main
liste de choses à faire le teckel genre
d'écouteurs fasse un bon buzz moi mais à
moi j'avais écouté je me rappelle cet
album là je l'avais coûté selon ce
qu'ils disaient de faire dit encore
aujourd'hui j'ai jamais entendu ce nom
qui sonne
ok j'ai jamais entendue vous avez quoi
le processus en trois mots dans le fond
c'était
fallait que je donne l'autre le fichier
wave ça c'est la première fois puis sur
leur site web il l'avait fait que tel
fichier le plus gros fichier
c'est exact c'est pas un mp3 une fois
que tu l'avais fallait j'ai aps le guide
des sites et des haut-parleurs blues de
cm2 sont que mon père avait acheté pour
la maison sutton est bon système de son
piste est comme dans les recommandations
qui avait été en haut de la gamme que
d'autres commandes et puis puis écouter
dans un endroit où ce qui est pas
vraiment de différence puis d'être
portés aussi attention à ce que tu
écoutes
parce que ce sont en fait ça peut être
vraiment bon si tu fais juste écouter
voici une masse l'entente paul klee
j'avais juste fait l'expérience d'être
des couches et d'écouté sur ses traits
je me rappelle même m'a dit j'ai pas
entendu de musique qui sonne comme ceux
ci c'est arrivé par un stage est ce que
j'aurais pris
est-ce que j'aurais pris un autre album
qui aurait coûté en circonstance le
serai sûrement été meilleur au si
quelqu'un met le compteur libère le
contexte pourrait presque de soi
aujourd'hui en prince album bloc c'est
comme ça tombe toujours d'autres
symboles découvrir sur youtube la
machine et j'ai fait seul c'est
l'histoire de ma vie lui voler un
syndrome tc déjà masteriser c'est déjà
comme tout écrasé mais c'est leur malade
le raid est simple cela va mal c'est de
la science en regrettant la série trop
[Musique]
fameux truc dans ma maison j'ai le dos
aussi de tous les plus grands breaks de
tous les talents ouais ça c'est pratique
mais sûrement puis samour jamais le cd
cd ça c'est des grands classiques de
drogue utiliser le fameux de les ai
plein
1 le fameux celui qui le break le plus
utilisé le fameux heineken d'asthme à
sortir c'est comme le top de la pop
music is a fait que chaque alioune tine
qui sort avec ce dogme la laddh
comment tu peux réinventer à partir de
ces gens qui ont fait ça doit bleus ils
savent maintenant 4 to 4 saint paul à ce
que tu donnes un crédit ou une ré
d'avoir quelqu'un qui avance c'est
vraiment on faisait attention à seront
taylor ont certaines bonnes âmes un
symbole de green man show accrophone
piétons on n'entendait pas parler postez
pas d y avait pas de gros revenus c'est
au québec produit beaucoup qui sont là
c'est évident mais on prendra pas non
plus sur la loue il n'y a pas de soi
mais vraiment le jeu fait pas je fais
pas attention du swiss a vu le jour ça
arrive c'est j'ai pas entendu parler
autour de moi des gens qui se sont fait
poursuivre si ça arrive comme ça peut
être un bon coup de pub on s'est
toujours dit que on dirait au moment
venu mais ya pas de grosses implique
qu'ils donnent évident de voler ces gars
vraiment appris quelque chose qui était
comme déjà tellement bon petit le juste
remis de remise en chantant dessus ça ça
mérite quelque chose effectivement mais
d'aller chercher les droits c'est
tellement compliqué que les gens le font
pas sont les twisted darwin bye bye plus
long excellent petit justin garner des
loups puissance c'est seul but moi on se
rend pas à demander c'est fou on en
parle juste avant les clubs de fou qui
de gaye et se fait retirer de youtube au
japon ouais on lit puis sur youtube le
mans parce que cela lui la guillette la
guette si c'est carrément un prix de
l'automne ses allures chilien kick
disney impute au travers déçu oui on est
là guide pas mal
comme ce qui d'après moi mais si j'ai
pensé c'est
c'est très rare mike morse baldor jouer
les causes propos she loves you tube
skank tel accord nantes et tout est là
peut quand même en option ce qui est sur
youtube si de moutons que ça vient des
simples dessins pour même si t'as pas
acheter le pack lotis sont sans toit qui
font passer après le clash est après je
l'avais acheté ouais je sais pas quand
savoir je l'avais tout tout est leur vie
quoi la proportion des que des trucs que
tu as joué versus que ce qui est
présenté
c'est égal j'ai toujours un gros trip de
jouer mais un instrument surtout la
baisse - les baseline tu ne peux pas
vraiment en crise
le res ces mêmes même du mend piano le
si le piano mais tellement il était
marrant du beau noir fait que des fois
on paraît suspect un accord le joue avec
la [ __ ] je le copie
je le cherche charge les notes de ce que
j'ai plus besoin de jouer mais la baise
on la guide dans la gorge de test à la
moindre à la moindre cordes qui faussent
faut comme ajuster le sait comme
l'emplacement pour le micro la guide
comme tel c'est l acoustique
quand j'ai fini la guide déchu ont
baissé irremplaçable enfin que 50 50
j'adore simpliste comme parce que j'aime
ça évite des stages ou d'internet ou un
tigre âge là taponne je sais où je m'en
vais là j place de l'entendre mais c'est
la pile baseline a joui des erreurs mais
commis trip way du défi l'image de
parler de khanabad quitté qui était venu
chez vous une fois puis avec toi puis
quelqu'un d'autre qui était comme le
rapporte l unité de la baisse sur une
haute et où nous nous tenons à quelqu'un
je sais pas trop
moi je l'enregistré lui ça me prendrait
une syncope pour amorcer la grosse note
puis il va les chercher à la faire
cesser cette rigueur
j'ai fait des 25 ans visé le one tech
choc
j'aime tellement ça découpe et puis dans
le découpage quelque chose de superbe
aussi j'ai commencé comme ça en
découpant en faisant des big faut que je
continue là dedans c'est pas du tout est
pas une excuse pour les gens qui sont
d'aider des performances et ils voient
que l'on mélange nos bases mais un objet
d'obsession j'ai appris tout ce que j'ai
déjà joué une fois je pourrais console
wii absolument y jeter un oeil
en fait ce qui est surprenant la
séquelle niveau harmonique l'été au
niveau des accords c'est plus complexe
que soit le parti qu'ils vont faire des
tournées à trop d'accord mais non mais
non c'est ce qui m'excite moi car j'ai
commencé à faire de la musique je me
disais si innocemment je me dis j'aime
aussi fun que ça jamais été fait après
je me sens quand cette année c'est pas
beau c'est presque pas de nice puis
après j'ai eu le trip 2 au moins ils en
sont toujours c'est toronto n'a comme
deux trois accords il faut qu'il y ait
un moment dans l'atonie s'y attendait
pas comme l'accord qui fait que tant de
peuples comme le goût de la réécouter et
puis j'ai toujours créatif accès a
toujours été la couleur de mes preuves
mais oui ça paraît d'une signature je
laisse rarement une alliée avec les
mêmes d'accord faut qu'ils aient un
moment le même temps la met dans la peau
spots ans c'est patent l'accord que
l'événement vaut dans leurs pieds puis
d'accord bah c'est ça moi dans la venue
du soir comme à ce qui m'a le plus plu
la musique c'est comme pu les accords et
10 ans est ainsi un accord
[Musique]
déprimant pitois n'était pas prêt ouais
comme au début quand c'était le rush
d'europe qui avait pas de notre jeu mais
juste le refrain comme une préparation
des prêts dans ce style ouais ouais mais
là j'ai mélangé mais ce que je sais qui
je suis puisque je faisais à ce de façon
qui fonctionne depuis longtemps
quelqu'un qui à l'époque on disait un
gars qui veut faire la gueule du rock
qui veut farabi de rap il entend tout de
suite je vais sortir un peu comme sa
lente agonie beatmaker trois syllabes
ouais ça se passe c'est fou comment les
bébés dans leur appui dans les pop ont
progressé puis on se sont mort fait au
fil du temps le team et on se regarde on
en a parlé je pense que riasq on avait
parlé de l'album seulement de gagner tu
parlais tantôt le foot au stade fantasy
viii puis avec genre des chorales qu'il
est complexe mais là c'est ça c'est le
mélange de la grosse force aérienne
planant déprimante mais qui donne un
genre le goût de battre dans rue en même
temps dedans commencé c'est ce qui est
au top mais j'ai compris après et après
ça s'est mélangé justement est revenu
dans l'est le jeu de une meilleur album
c'est une immense production ça reste un
titre à bilbo aérien mais des chorales
depuis des fenêtres de quoi
effectivement ça a été une phase assez
jeune mais qui a servi à quelque chose
qui ait fait quelque chose qui pour moi
existait pas la sélection réinventer la
fox qui avait amené des jazzman la tube
ça c'est comme parfaite après ça c'est
pas devenu un courant comme ça mais
c'est quand même au top c'est
parallèlement hottelard adelman ya des
choses extraordinaires de complexes
qu'ils soient un peu d influence par
exemple ou de thé je peux comment bien
formuler la question est est-ce que tu
prends mettons ce qui te fait triper
dans des projets à toi de ta musique à
toi ou mettons les projets de karim dans
l'espèce de désir de défaut qu'un peu de
danse un peu
ob dans tes projets de rap aussi parce
que j'ai comme l'impression ces deux ces
deux choses un peu difficiles je les ai
déjà pensé à faire un genre de projet
hybride entre ces deux pays phares de
chaque prod est un peu hybride ce soit
ayant joué dans des styles très
différents mais comme il est clairement
toujours quelque chose demain je pensais
que l'auto influence moto influence mais
c'est quand même j'ai fait une comédie
musicale avec base complètement à sauter
sa pelle polyvalente puis j'ai produit
toute la musique de sopi j'ai été à
maintes reprises parce que quand j'ai
commencé mon album solo je me suis auto
et florence et g j'avais bu deux frères
[Musique]
je te veux aller dans cette voie là mais
tentant toujours les flancs ce que j'ai
fabriqué spécial pita musique la musique
à karim c'est qui peut pas dire si quel
style de musique
ouais ouais tu vois là dessus c'est
tellement melting pas de pain l'enfant
qui s'est s'est produit un peu comme du
rap aussi je pense les gentils mélangés
aux personnages bélanger à l'époque on a
clairement mis le doigt sur quelque
chose de super efficace de la mort en
plein carême a dit qu'on était un bide
que j'avais fait un remix d'une grosse
méchante de trad
watson c'est le remix de peau de serpent
qui est une tonne de motos théoriquement
fly et d'un gros beats le commode robin
des toits
moi j'ai déjà doublé puis j'ai fait une
veillée avec ceux ci je suis pas le
temps enfin c'est ce soit un album de
remixes notamment l'omd le pouce est
comme ça est complètement après tout ça
ça a été le plus gros coup et veulent de
tout le monde moi langage de calais
c'est fabuleux l'histoire tu vois que
ses seules ces dix minutes
farimex d'une grosse tonnes de trappes
qui s'adonnent qu'il allait la carrière
car c'est au détour de jouer quelque
chose qui sans vie alors justement par
là dedans le même défaut que très peu en
mode je continue toujours invendu je
gisais je me borne à garder un truc
so foot et à la claque est comme une
espèce de pilier des fois je me dis avec
goût de changer de nom de favre un autre
style de musique mais continuer sur le
cd cd qui tourne je sais pas ce que
l'opa pour moi j'ai touché un peu à
l'apogée de ce que je pouvais faire dans
ce style là sur le dernier album que moi
je trouve encore meilleur que le premier
selon tous mes proches cescom puis le
pire c est un petit peu moins
je ne suis pas fait un numéro alors
j'avais fait un numéro un total c'est
donc avec le jouet de l'année club et je
suis l'exemple même si j'ai fait une
super performance s'est posée pour ce
qui est important c'était plus pauvres
je les fais pour moi je me suis tu te
prouver que ça puis je suis prêt je
comme prêts à donner l'impression qui
aimait tant c est quoi de plus proche de
ce cas là claire fait au niveau du style
vraiment dans le rap slam savoir le
personnes aux iphone j'imagine le
personnage parce qu'il prend le maquis
avec un plus gros transfert de public
rien à voir en fait ça se touche
vraiment potentiel solo à la cale sas
touche dans la mesure où ces des fans
qui savent que je fais ce puits qui
connaissent le personnage mais il écoute
paul les deux fils de musique soit c'est
un peu ma question tantôt par rapport à
l'hybride matin c'était un peu c'est un
peu là je voulais aller je me disais si
tu quelque chose qui passe
j'ai l'impression que ce serait un
projet complètement unique 6-2 comme toi
prendre sorti du lot et le croiser le de
croiser ce que tu fais dans le rap est
ce que tu faisais dans un plomb se porte
même si je suis là c'est un peu ce que
je pense avoir essayé de faire sur mon
album
ok si certaines chansons le qui pour moi
c'est comme du gros la grosse prod ti
west coast la trappe mais avec
complètement les arrangements
orchestrale et les instruments analogue
dessus c'est un peu ce que j'ai fait
puis tu vois ces cds en turquie qu'à moi
je trais j'aime vraiment résultats mais
les gens ils sont un peu perdus par être
malade moi même temps d'enfants ont fait
que j'ai un peu ça peut ça que j'ai
voulu faire ce que j'ai fait mais là je
suis dans une phase des bâtons je fais
un album de rap clope c'est la chose qui
me ferait le plus strict est prêt je
sais pas comment je le coquet qui qui
suis-je la dame oui mais là j'ai vu des
doudous cheveux longs français à
marseille qui complètement chez les
noirs humeur semblait presque c'est un
genre de gros méchants qui fait du trap
jeter tout existe maintenant absolument
tout sûr que je pas gros méchas je pense
que c'est plus que je sais pas c'est ma
phase de base sourit pas de souris parce
que j'étais en interaction avec tout et
tim payne alors je t'ai vu je t'ai vu
avant sa revanche sur le dos nu à quai
c'est bon aussi
un mystère qui plane autour de toi
peut-être que toi de ton point de vue tu
trouves pas d'enjeu si je lui eus je me
suis fait dire par le prince henri on
sait pas trop dans une union du projet
nice personnes c'est sur la zone de
limoges ce qui met chaque entrevue dans
chaque moule puis mais les gens savent
pas toujours sur quel pied danser non
c'est ça puis je me fais dire comme dans
des directions faudra faire attention à
ça ou peut-être plus que la rivier
sauver le jeu terme à un moment où
joseph encore ça c'est moi tu sais
pourquoi je serai de l'air plus de ça ou
d'être plus adapté à un petit 6 vient à
ce que s'adapte à ce dans mieux mais moi
je courais pas après j'ai fait de la
musique dans la vie je devenais un peu
une phase publique aussi grand public
mais à cause que j'aime et ce que les
gens aiment ce que je faisais pour la
course commence à poser des questions le
temps avance un peu rendu à la course
c'est parce que si t'as pas toucher à
ces deux mondes
danton momentum votre idée de la pâte le
score lyon levé faut c'est au moment où
tu te mets à penser à tout ce que la
magie que le feu commence à 7 ans quand
la musique devient trop business qui
évite phone - même ton personnage
personnel qui est remis en question
quand j'y pense c'est débile un mois
j'ai jaugé volume et je commence à faire
trop attention
qu'est ce que je dégage vie je te peu là
dans ce sens il c'est le deuxième album
me fait prendre conscience de plein
d'aspects ou moi j'étais pu j'étais plus
temps à ma place dans l'intention le feu
le c'est vraiment important il faut
vraiment l'entretenir et s creed se
détacher de l'image d'hugo beau gage
voilà elle soit aussi dit vouloir se
dégager de sauve à long terme en eau du
sol entassé soupe ailleurs
c'est battant déjà trop beau il trop
bonnes volontés faut faire attention
le prévu la paire afin de faire
attention c'est chaque fois qu'on voit à
la clair que ce soit en entrevue ou pour
un spectacle sur youtube des vidéos des
spectacles sont uploadées ya tout le
temps que l'autre des gens qui dit pas
grand chose j'aime ça se pense que
c'était à tout le monde en parle un peu
le vrai moi si je pense que c'était un
moment à part qui est tout le monde est
à 6 mi temps j'ai commencé entre eux
c'est moi qui vous parle
mais après sa précieuse et comme le
pendant du ciss le faut laisser passer
ça mais si ça mais je trouve ça malade
c'est comme meetic l'armada qui parlent
plus que d'autres les mécanos et bâtir
des gens qui elop tout le monde s'est
montrée tekki qu'ils ont assis leur il
le montre qu'à nice plus que ce qu'il
fait ici je connais plus il faut 8
c'est parce qu'il ya un conférencier
dans l'équipe je vois faire mais voici
ces points c'est moins évident mais
dallas et c'était cool c'est d'ailleurs
la journée même puis on est débarqué le
jeu sans arrêt de la suite en face du
clip la famille ouais vous avez tourné
les clips journée la même journée que
tout le monde n'a pas planté dans
l'explosive n'est atlanta la soie la
maquilleuse ouais bon c'était comme
enlever la suite de guerres d'en face
j'ai commencé justement en mode moi je
voudrais pas dire un mot ça serait bien
que tout le monde parle comme j'ai
surtout savoir qu'elle s'était faite
journée
mais ça c'est le genre d'affaires sur
cet appel le duc en ciel tout ce que te
sourit le pam a laissé grand chose d'eux
au québec et partout le plus important
pour une classe digne ou stress environ
gag
d'où la tonine on en parle à la
nous invitons votre balle et c'est ça
qui fait qu'en l'état le lot
on sait que les potées au sein de
laquelle je n'ai pas vu temps à lire la
saison depuis avant d'éjecter vrai je
pense que c'est ce que j'aurais même pu
écouter les paroles n'avaient pas les
noms de tonnes je suis l'homme armé
physiquement le rat contribuent le plus
que je peux et de plus en plus d'air
mais autant pas mal donné l'album c'est
ça j'ai vu aussi présents parce que tu
es un espèce de crise identitaire qui
peut se placer au sein d'un groupe quand
et comme pas les gars qui tout le temps
au front justement l'équipe leçon
défense puis en présence ici puis là je
faisais un petit peu plus le jeu serait
pas mal plus confortable de dmd moment
où tu chantes tu arrives en avant qui
chante depuis tout temps la qualité de
pouvoir chanter bien rappelle que des
fois j'en veux à baignade est super bon
chanteur d'un groupe aussi mais c'est
comme le chantait bien pas bien capable
de le faire jusqu'à de chanter comme
billet je trouve ça moins note à plein
au niveau santé en europe 1 j'ai jamais
trouvé ma voie aussi d'europe si j'ai
comme j'ai commencé en criant profonde
impôts cgi com switch edwards était plus
sûr de jeter qui monte juste 2 justement
fou qui a capoté sur le dernier paru ce
que j'ai fait puis là j'ai pris une voie
une fois que j'avais jamais pris ta voix
c'est la voie la plus proche de tous
âges étaient proches de parler mais tu
es comme très grave
le moment si je vois des voix
j'étais au personnage un jour je vais
peut-être trouvé bama ma voix mais les
6e qui sait ce qui est une scène avec
ses rapports lebel et ses rapports avec
des rapports que kiki sorte jeunes pij
avec une voix grave et là oui justement
un gars comme vous qui
le meilleur c'est ton caractère qui
titre pas trop réfléchi a comme moi
l'enfant qui est dessus dans cette voie
des gens qui ont inventé un iron inventé
un style avec là on voit aussi des
sorties de caisses vendues de la musique
et moi excuse moi je te le mardi comme
annoncé ça les gueux légaux réinvente
avec leur propre personnalité des trucs
des croisements c'est vraiment
respect merci que la position à la fin
je suis fou le biais des arts et de la
poésie
je pense bien se repose sur l'écouté
c'est comme non écoutés
[Musique]